thank you so much for the organizers to
for inviting me here and to given me an
opportunity to talk and for sticking on
the last day to all of you this work is
I think your dad has given a great talk
yesterday and I will try to relate also
what we do and kind of draw parallels
when appropriate to to the work that was
presented yesterday we are also
interested in disease mechanisms but we
came to it from a from a different
approach and kind of thinking of
networks just as tools not as the
primary information propagation tool
sort of so i think it's a it's the other
side of the coin and then we'll see what
we can do next so this work is primarily
done by Isis ms lanique with a senior
PhD in my lab busy students so thinking
about the disease mechanism in complex
human diseases and in complex human
disease we expecting multiple proteins
to be disrupted right and what's coming
out from the literature and from this
kind of from the clinical and biological
literature is that different genes may
also be disrupted in different ways so
in say this three gene to our example we
have a in the first gene and patient one
we have me sense variant in patient two
in the same gene but it might be a
regulatory variant like an enhancer very
end in gene to it may be yet another
aberration like a splicing or de novo
missense mutation aberration and patient
three in patients five and six is gene
three but it's something else but all of
this together so any of these things
could happen to cause the phenotype of
the disease or multiple of these things
would happen so this makes a discovery
of the actual mechanism really really
difficult where the tools that study one
gene at a time right so there
the data that can be used in principle
to identify these methods is diverse let
us say right so there's a lot of
variation coding and non-coding
variation than there are structural
aberrations of the genome there's
methylation fortunately
post-translational modifications etc and
all of these things can affect the
disease so in G was people that people
have started by looking at variation
across common variation across the
genome they've looked at non-coding
variants but they have only looked at
common ones and so G was has not
resulted in kind of the kind of the
breaking breakthrough results that
people have expected when we started
looking at rare variants and then we
started looking at we started looking
mostly at codon variation right because
it's really really hard to attribute
rare variation to some kind of cohesive
unit we simply don't have the power to
detect the rare variation and non-coding
areas of the genome and so but there are
many many variant aggregation methods
that use that combine this variance and
have the power with smaller sample sizes
to actually identify the genes of
interest even without using the
network's then people started using
networks and of course networks gave a
lot of more power to detect the the
genes involved in the disease but there
are sometimes there are problems with
validation and replication but that's
that's not the only problem the problem
is that we're still stuck with jeans
whether we are using that works on or
not so for the networks at least in this
area we're looking at gene aggregation
and variant aggregation methods there
are multiple tools so dapple I think is
the favorite tool that's used that
and there are several other tools and
then yesterday wrote that stock so this
I want to say that the top was to
discover the disease mechanism but the
evaluation is quite different from the
way that these tools work which are
Association tools right they are trying
to figure out whether we can explain how
much variance we can explain enough
status of the patient in a case control
type of scenario and so in our case we
compared to dmg was which is another one
of the network propagation tools but it
had it had a code available so we use it
off the ones that were so dmg was it
takes the p-values as the labels for the
nodes and then it starts from the sea
genes and it includes greedily jeans and
the gene set according to the network if
they increase the test statistic some
test statistic that they have defined
and kind of a small limitation and this
might need to be adjusted by small
limitation is that to include the gene
and another gene and asset it has to
improve the kind of the variance
explained by ten percent which is a lot
as you get a bigger and bigger set it
becomes very difficult to improve the
accuracy by ten percent so that's a kind
of one of the limitations and the output
is a set of genes that are ranked by
strength of association with a phenotype
so I think this this this part can be
also done to kind of extend the work
that was presented yesterday to be
comparable directly to these methods so
the disadvantages of most of the
existing methods is that in certain
scenarios were the network's i used the
statistics of the genes are pre computed
in advance and then you propagate the
information so some kind of label is
said ok this gene that has this many
mutation or is mutated or not and this
kind of things are pre computed in
advance right it's not but
mostly with the p-values especially it
depends on the size of the original
discovery data set too so that's a
that's one limitations precomputed and
then the information is propagated
across the network and of course the it
ignores the the intergenic variation as
well so the way we started thinking
about the disease my kind of discovering
a more global disease mechanism is we
said okay we have a say heritable
disease and what happens with the
heritable disease multiple protein
functions are disrupted how can they be
disrupted well they can be disrupted
either by the quality so the coding of
the protein or what it looks like or by
the level and the gene expression so
there are there are some ways in which
the coding variants also affect the gene
expression but most of the variants they
kind of affect the quality of the
protein and that's notnot modulating the
level and of course the gene expression
is really kind of an agglomeration of
all the things that can happen in a
regulatory sense right C and bs would
affect the jeans and a gene expression
way the DNA methylation micrornas and a
lot of the intergenic variations so this
is a my motivation for the including the
gene expression as you did yesterday but
so some of the things that we miss in in
this way in this model there are
definitely if there are novel proteins
like prions and cut jeans and cut
fusions you would have to figure out
that separately but the we have to deal
with noisy gene expression we have to
deal with with all the usual things that
people kind of have to deal with when
they start including gene expression all
right so once we include the gene
expression we are now able to survey all
of these different methods at all so all
of these different data also by proxy so
what we do
how do we incorporate gene expression
and coding information we basically have
excellent variance and we also compute
the pre computed harmfulness for each of
the variance and that we do with a card
or a nevar most recently existing tools
for computing the harmfulness priors and
then we have the expression levels for
the regulatory aberration and then we
have an aberration / / gene it's a kind
of a score and then of course we look at
all of the genes simultaneously and we
include the G network for further
propagation so this is what it looks
like as a graphical model that we
actually implemented we have this is
this is just for one gene so the the
field in triangles are they actual data
and the night fielding triangles are
this predictions predictions that we
pre-compute in advance of the algorithm
so what we do is we have this data and
we combine harmfulness and the coding
variation information so each one of the
triangles is actually a variant and
observed variant in that gene across all
the patients that we have in a cohort so
we have this kind of scores / / gene
that combine first harmfulness and the
evidence and then we have a factor that
combines all of these variant / variant
essentially scores now to into a score
of codeine variations for purging okay
we also have a quantity aberration score
per gene as well and then we have a
course a factor which combines the
quantity and the quality of the scores
into a gene state and we do it so here
there are three genes but reality is we
don't really pre-filter genes so we have
the 20,000 genes that we have in the
data this would be the the size of the
model and this is per patient and of
course a single patient is in an
instantiation is a single enunciation of
this graphical model yep
yes yes yeah so one of the good things
about this method of course we want to
have coding and different and expression
data for the same patients because then
we can say what is the matter how is the
mechanism disrupted in that patient is
it in a regulatory or the coding sense
but we actually don't have to have that
information to still be able to do the
inference across the patients it will
just be integrated over okay so and the
phenotype here in the simplest case that
i will be showing the results its case
control so patient status so in at the
end of the day it's a supervised problem
we use networks this is how the networks
are used as a prior or soft constraint
and this each factor basically says
whether the genes are whether the genes
are connected in a network of our that
we are exploring so for you for example
in by a grid or the networks that we we
discussed yesterday yes I will explain
exactly how they affect the model so
these are the factor based models and
usually in a kind of classic MRFs there
is this parameter parameterised factor
which is the same for every node right
but we have a slightly more difficult
problem when gene networks it's not a
nice grid and there are other problems
like degree distribution start to matter
a lot because there's such a diversity
right so the large no degrees and the
discrepancy between degrees can really
skew the type of message passing so I
should mention that we use message
passing like a Hopi belief propagation
for influence in our model but they can
skew this this kind of propagation
also in the complex disease when we are
talking about the disease mechanism we
expect only a few genes to be on in the
end so we that's a hyper parameter in
our model so let's say 10 20 100 genes
to be on the overall in the network
which means it's going to be very hard
to two very important to keep to keep
that constraint and not let let let it
grow out of proportion and in our work
we made an assumption that if we do not
have the data to support a gene to be on
this was my question to you yesterday
the gene will not be on just because
it's a neighbor's in the network so we
implement that with a directed a
symmetric parameterised networks and
this is what it looks like so I guess
this is more what what it looks like so
the off genes we're trying to make it so
that the off genes are not informative
so if the gene if the neighbor is off
then your probability of being on an
office fifty percent if the genus were
however low it is the prior if the gene
is one then it matters then that
information gets gets propagated and we
have this Delta parameter which is also
pre computed based on a degree now I'd
like to give you intuition about how
Delta is set so scenario one where we
have a gene where all the neighbors are
kind of on right and I think in most
propagation
the network propagation methods this
would basically imply that the gene that
the inner gene will be on because this
this is this is what these methods are
meant to kind of do but of course for us
if there is no evidence from the data we
do not want a gene to be on and so it
might have a very little info there
little support for for being on but it
has to have some data of its own and in
a few patients that is it it's affected
in a kind of coding or regulatory sense
so the scenario one and the scenario two
is that again there is no evidence from
the data the degree is high so by chance
several of the genes will be on and of
course we want the small contribution
also not to be able to turn it on so
this is a kind of the intuition and this
is an upper bound and when we compute
Delta we basically set it to to this
value and we have some low very low
prior over all the genes to be one right
it's just very very low prior then we
have the max network messages which is
basically the scenarios where the genes
are on that they're trying to propagate
this information I am in the disease
mechanism to its neighbors and weak
network messages where they are not they
are not on and then we are trying to
propagate that information the D is the
degree of the node that it's propagated
to and m is the putative size of the
mechanism that we assume there's a I was
thinking I say it's like a like a tax
break so this is this is our our
approach and it's actually not that
different one you think about loopy
belief propagation our network with
these parameters it's similar to
propagate in doing diffusion over a
network over a weighted network right
where the weights kind of depend on the
degree were corrected by the dig for
third degree but
we the difference the major difference
is that it's because it's part of the
global model we are not set with the
labels at all times right we propagate
the information and then it goes back to
integrate with the evidence from the
data and then we keep doing that so this
is I think the major difference in in in
the kind of this graphical model type of
approach where it says taking a network
labeling the nodes and then propagating
information on that label no that's kind
of it's a one pass one iteration of this
method in a way and also we do not
because of these kind of assumptions
that we made about what the disease
mechanisms will be and should look like
we do not realize much on the topology
of the network by design because that's
what we choose so there is no way for in
our method for a note to be on if all of
its neighbors are on so the tp53 will
not always be on it has to have the
evidence from the data which it's in
breast cancer it would be but not in
every cancer okay so I'll talk a little
bit about simulation so we validate it
we kind of compared and looked at the
robustness of the method primarily in
the simulated data because we simply
don't know the truth in any of the
complex diseases that we are currently
studying so what we did is we simulated
exome data through kind of the
evolutionary process this crook of model
from 2009 and we randomly selected genes
nearby jeans and a network and then we
looked everybody who had operations and
those jeans were labeled as patients and
then we sampled n cases and uncontrolled
and this is the scenario and the number
of the genes that were sampled we looked
at 10 20 50 and 100 I think I have more
for the smaller kind of sample sizes so
just to remind this is dmg was it takes
as input as p-values so it first pre
processes the data in univariate fashion
to identify which genes important and
then it greedily adds genes to the set
so that's what we what we
comparing to two now so in the simulated
mechanism of ten ten genes it's a
sensitivity and a precision and you can
see that and the sample size is on a x
axis so sketch o is the most commonly
most widely used method for variant
aggregation rare variant aggregation in
processing exome data and Association
studies so this is ghetto which obtained
obtaining p values from the schedule
method and looking at the dmg west type
of network aggregation of course here
there could be different ways of
aggregating so you can see that as for
the small sample sizes it's very
difficult to identify the true genes
regardless of the method I think what's
interesting is that with respect to just
obtaining the p-values and looking at
the network dmj was is less sensitive to
the smaller sample size right because if
there is a way to have ranked p values
and if that ranking doesn't change it
can still keep adding the genes even if
there is not enough evidence where
scatter just wouldn't call it a G
finding because it doesn't have the
power but unfortunately as it as the
sample size get a larger the networks
are not in this particular case and not
really given more power to identify so
in some sense you could argue here that
if you had n going to infinity you
wouldn't need the network it wouldn't
need them at work maybe maybe that's the
right kind of approach of course here as
for the precision that it identifies the
problem of dmg was is that it identifies
genes of guilty by association tries to
first add the direct neighbors and in
our cases we sampled direct and
second-degree neighbors and the
second-degree neighbors without the
first-degree neighbors is really hard to
add so in in our kind of explorations of
real data we did not find
and the likely needs subnetworks to be
really implicated by the data and so we
kind of wanted to relax that assumption
assumption in our method allows us to do
that I see the show that it is the
modules should be connected tightly
connected but it is connected you know
you had this high-profile publication in
the science nature I think I'm being
recorded so we'll take this question
offline if you don't mind because this
is this is real data is changing kudos
you show us the performance of their DVD
was what it is a connected we can do
that fee of course it's not true in
reality but for brushes sake of course
we know the for the 20 genes of course
with the same sample size it becomes
harder to identify the genes and the dmg
was I think because of primarily because
of that ten percent constraint of adding
it to the to the
the gene set it becomes more difficult
because now each gene really has less
less penetrance in a way and so the
evidence is smaller and so it can add a
few more genes to a set but it becomes
harder to find any genes that have ten
percent improvement there's a example of
sensitivity to noise kind of saying I'm
not sure we have a conversion the best
way to represent this data but if you
remove edges right if you remove edges
then the dmg was so what you have to
look at the median and if you remove the
edges then dmg was of course is affected
right because now it cannot add the
genes that it needs to add the [ __ ] if
you add edges it's not so bad because
since it adds genes greedily the the
genes that it wants to where they're
still in a set of the neighbors and so
it will have access to those jeans and
still can add those jeans so the
difference is not much when you start
perturbing when when the networks are
noisy by edging spurious ages the
removing of the edges and the
connectivity makes a difference to to
have an access to those jeans also this
is the robustness of our method so our
method here is and pink the red is no
expression not a gene expression the
lambda it says a lambda which I didn't
introduce before this is saying that
it's fifty percent code in fifty percent
regulatory so and fifty percent of the
patients it will be mutation and fifty
percent it will be regulation so of
course if you remove expression has the
biggest the biggest effect on the
results whereas if it's you remove
harmful as the priors that we have the
harmfulness and the network's the effect
is a little bit less so you can see that
the network's matter more with a smaller
sample size but as the samples I grows
even though we sampled genes from the
network removing the network during the
inference process does not affect us too
much so one of the advantages
defiance's join subnetworks i honestly
from the exploration of the real data
that that we've had and worked with a
lot of different public and kind of
local data sets I have not found that
it's really sub networks that come out
as the as the genes perhaps because we
don't have enough data but I think that
this has been our experience with with
the real data so I'm happy that the
method is actually not as sensitive to
that and also it's less sensitive to the
noise and the network removing edges as
well as adding edges so this is the TCGA
breast cancer data hands also my
question yesterday we try to look at
more we had the exome and RNA sync data
we looked at because we kind of have
this case control scenario we looked at
each subtype against other against the
rest o against other subtypes so in our
case will be very interested in luminal
a because we in luminal cancer a and B
because we have a collaborator who is
willing to test the function of the
genes that we find so comparing to other
methods this these are kind of variant
aggregation and also dmg was comparing
to other methods we found a lot more
genes and that that were found to be
important the other methods find either
got a three or C alpha and C alpha finds
pik3ca and of course if this gene is not
if this gene is not found this is like
for luminal cancer this is it means the
method is not working well unfortunately
none of these genes are directly
connected in a network and so the dmg
was was not able to use the power that
it has from integrating network data and
so it actually didn't find any of them
of the genes this is this is the the p.i
k3 see a gene this is from the sea by a
portal it takes
its present and forty-two percent of the
breast cancer patient so I think it's
kind of nice that there is some some
kind of an exclusion hypothesis in the
end we didn't put it in but I think
what's what's also interesting and what
actually is a bit of a disadvantage of
our methods what what the graphical
models do over the random variables
right there trying to explain the data
they are trying to fit the data and give
the best likely for them so if we add
jeans if we turn on jeans that explain
some of the data for patients that have
sort of mutations in other genes it says
well this patient has already explained
so you don't get much of a benefit from
detecting it but for the gene of course
and I think in some sense and network
propagation methods this is not a
problem for for other genes right you
take the whole evidence across all the
patients that you can combine so from
from our preliminary kind of analysis we
are speculating that in luminal breast
cancer the the coding variation can
explain about fifty-five percent of the
patients we found in our method that the
codeine and regulatory jointly for the
same genes coding and regulatory
variation isn't present in about fifteen
percent of the patient and regulatory
about twenty percent of the patients so
sridhar yesterday asked me if you could
identify this with a differential
expression and the answer is no because
if its twenty percent you might be able
to build good signatures but you will
not be able to identify the actual
disease mechanism this if what we are
finding is the true disease mechanism we
are just applied for a grant to to test
all of this in the lab of course I want
to give you another vignette about yes
yes what doing
and another vignette with is much
smaller cancer this is medulloblastomas
and we're working with Mike Taylor at
our hospital who has over a thousand
patients of course in this case we
actually had germline holics whole
genome sequencing data so for the
germline we had both germline and
somatic mutations but the numbers of
samples for which we had the sequencing
data was much much smaller so the 31
sonic hedgehog patients they looks
usually very very different and kind of
in terms of differential expression but
they were looking for genetic signature
so basically these would be the
predisposing signatures to get in this
childhood cancer and so what we do is we
can estimate the posterior probability
of each patient having a specific let's
say subtype right so we picked sonic
hedgehog and classify the patient's as
hot sonic hedgehog or not so these are
the posterior probabilities for each of
the patients and you can see that in
sonic hedgehog could a lot of them have
a high zero probability of being sonic
hedgehog and the other subtypes not
except for this too but there are some
patients that were not characterized as
a sonic hedgehog and what we can do in
in this case as we can start looking at
them kind of what was the reason that it
was classified so for each individual
patient we can go back and look at the
posterior probabilities over the genes
that we would implicate for that in in
the disease mechanism to implicate for
that specific patient so kind of trying
to figure out what actually happens so
page one is of course regulating a sonic
hedgehog at some level and so this is it
makes sense so for page one mutation to
be the highest but for this little one
is a sufu and so for mutation is
associated with major bus doma but
they're also whole slew of other
mutations something is else is wrong
with these patients and so we're
actually working with Mike Taylor now to
identify the sub sub types or subtypes
of subgroups or subgroups of subtypes
and in sonic hedgehog it turns out that
there are three or four based on other
type of omics data so this this is I
like having probabilistic models in that
sense because we can go back and try to
figure out what actually happened and
the data according to our model and we
can have hypotheses for a testing like
we kind of discussed yesterday so with
that I would like to thank you and my
lab and especially eysies this is his
thesis work and my collaboration
medulloblastoma and breast cancer what
are your heart assaulted about it lack
of connection the network because she
shall take the capsule thing to breast
cancer genes commenting that are not
connected internet work some of them is
just because which that preposterous
whether it's just and yeah in my network
they are connected so so it was network
it is in the south side that is that the
lack of our data in the network that you
don't see them connected of you feel
so my experience with computational
biology in general was that I started
with networks because this is it social
networks in my PhD and it was a natural
way to kind of get into the field and I
very quickly realized that there is a
lot of noise and a network and so if we
use network as a given it's it's hard to
know what is then what is not and that
makes it difficult to interpret the
results so is that the algorithm that is
wrong or is it the in you know the data
that we are supplying it and so it is
possible that they are truly really
connected and we simply don't know some
of them are connected and some of them
are not connected yet we use by a grid
because of the there there were several
suggestions yesterday that we can try
but I think the good thing is that while
we benefit from having the network as a
prior with we are not hampered if we
have the data supporting those jeans
we're not hampered by not having those
connections in so for me having the
connections that I truly believe are
there so kind of having reducing the
false positive effect I think is is more
important here for other methods is
different of course methods that rely on
connectivity a different answer may be
false negatives that much worse and so
maybe for dmg was we should have used a
string and aggregation and much much
bigger networks
may I replace my questions because that
was not philosophy cousin concrete about
the matter so at the end you'll find the
genes if you go back you probably find
some relationship between them if
they're in the same diseases even if
they're not connected in our noisy
network we that's that's the whole goal
right but then we are starting to look
at whether they are co-regulated whether
the transcription factor is that
potentially one is the transcription
factor of something else which is
cascading down something else and and
that allows us by generating its
hypothesis to uncover new biology yes we
think that there is some relation
between these networks but also examples
that I'm giving right the method the
motivation of the method it was a bit
tricky because the motivation of the
methods was for complex disease not not
necessarily cancer right and but the
results that I gave you for cancer and
so I think there's slightly different
assumptions and there are slightly
different advantages and disadvantages
of what we will get but I think this is
one way if we rely if we don't
necessarily strongly rely on the
connectivity of the network then we can
generate hypotheses don't cover new
biology because we will go to try to
figure out what what what is actually
the mechanism functionally of these
genes that we are finding right because
ultimately we want to figure out the
cure another treatment programs
so in your noise analysis were you
dropping out edges or jeans or edges so
have you tried so thinking about
something that's a little bit outside of
cancer or maybe the you know genes might
be less well measured have you thought
about dropping out sort of pull jeans or
even sets of cancer genes to see how it
responds to certain let's press less
full data in here I'm not sure that
would help us much because we include
all the genes that are that we have data
for we have if we have coding variation
or a differential expression for these
genes we can include them and see
singletons even if they are not in the
network so there is no point so I guess
I'm wondering so if you included them a
single thats how much does your
performance drop off so thank you
something if it doesn't right we are
finding this joint knows they are not
necessarily Singleton's but we are not
the point is we will still find a note
if it's greatly supported by the by the
data so i think we are kind of doing so
we don't have the simulation experiments
to show exactly that but we do have real
data in that in our network behaves like
that and we are able to find them so if
you start thinking about looking at
diseases that are associated with genes
that are not be as well
things like it doesn't it looks like
from the data analysis that we have done
that it does not affect method yeah well
I showed in a in the robustness
experiment there is a bit of a drop but
not much and of course as the size of
the data grows you get more evidence for
implicating genes and then but it does
help if yeah it just doesn't hurt as
much all right let's thank the speaker
again